lok arnstadt wegschütten weil viele den
impfstoff von astrazeneca ablehnen
wollen ihn einige ministerpräsidenten
jetzt für alle freigegeben
bitte nicht stehenbleiben in düsseldorf
gibt es ein verweis verbot und die frage
wie sinnvoll solche regeln im freien
sind und deutsche erfolge bei der heim
wm gold dem teamspringen und silber im
teamwettbewerb der nordischen
kombination
die nachrichten nicht anders heute mit
christian sievers an diesem sonntag
einen guten abend hinein und auch ann
kristin otto die den sport hat nachher
wunderbaren abend schluss mit der
strengen reihenfolge beim impfen mit dem
impfstoff von astrazeneca hin zu impfen
wer will dafür plädieren vor dem bund
länder treffen in der kommenden woche
gleich mehrere ministerpräsidenten
hintergrund ist die tatsache dass von
astrazeneca aktuell viele dosen
ungenutzt bleiben
die schwächsten schützen das war die
regel am anfang erste priorität hatten
und haben alten und pflegeheime sowie
menschen über 80 jahre genau für sie
hatte allerdings die ständige
impfkommission den astra zeneca stoff
nicht empfohlen
seit mittwoch können jetzt auch
lehrerinnen und lehrer sowie
erzieherinnen und erzieher geimpft
werden
sie wurden vorgezogen und das wird wohl
nicht die letzte änderung in der
reihenfolge bleibt thomas konsum
die produktion läuft sonst stockte das
präparat von astrazeneca
es befindet sich eher im schrank als in
der blutbahn verschwendung sagen nun
einige ministerpräsidenten
sie ist wichtig dass wir bei astrazeneca
so schnell wie möglich alles raus
bringen an impfdosen und kämpfen können
jetzt gibt es neue priorisierung das ist
gut für lehrkräfte erzieherin und
polizisten aber was dann übrig bleibt
das sollte man einfach öffnen und das
sollte sich dann derjenige impfen lassen
können der sich impfen lassen will
astrazeneca für jeden genug ist da 2,1
millionen dosen verimpft wurden aber nur
363.000 entspricht 17 prozent vor einer
woche waren es 15
zum vergleich von beyond advisor wurden
46 prozent der vorräte gespritzt viel
britischer impfstoff aber wenige pixel
an mangelndem willen liegt das wohl
nicht mehr lehrkräfte kita kräfte sie
standen vergangene tage schlange aber
andere dürfen sich gar nicht anstellen
wegen der festen reihenfolge kritik auch
vom sächsischen landeschef die
priorisierung ist ein mittel der
mangelverwaltung und sollte für
astrazeneca zügig aufgehoben werden geht
zu weit sagen andere
für alle reichte im stoff gar nicht
aus meiner sicht falsch die
priorisierung der älteren menschen muss
im vordergrund stehen ich würde sogar
den astra eben stoff jetzt für die über
65 irgendein setzen das hat sich ganz
klar gezeigt dass er dort
krankenhauseinweisungen und tote
vermeiden kann
argumente pro astrazeneca auch die
ständige impfkommission will über
empfehlungen aktualisieren es soll
zügiger vorangehen im kampf gegen korona
und dann gucken wir jetzt auf die
aktuellen zahlen laut
robert-koch-institut liegt die inzidenz
unverändert bei 63,8 die täglichen
neuinfektionen bewegen sich auf einem
ähnlichen niveau wie vor einer woche
sieben 1890 wurden am morgen gemeldet
ein plus von 214
außerdem wurden 157 weitere todesfälle
in zusammenhang mit 19 registriert keine
zahlen basis also für entwarnung
gleichzeitig zieht es die menschen
natürlich nach draußen
gerade bei schönem wetter und dann wird
es schon mal eng
manche großstädte greifen zu neuen
regeln verweilt verbot ist ein unschönes
wort es sieht auch geldbußen vor etwa
für stehen bleiben an der falschen
stelle
ariane gödel berichtet aus düsseldorf
polizei und ordnungsamt kontrollieren
gemeinsam denn die regeln sind streng an
diesem wochenende in düsseldorf auf
einer länge von zweieinhalb kilometern
sitzen verboten genauso wie länger
stehen bleiben
gnade vor recht in diesem fall die
angesprochenen geben sich einsichtig wir
müssen das bußgeld von 35 euro nicht
zahlen
verstöße gegen das verbot gibt es viele
sie liegen deswegen kein alkohol also
wir sind einfach nur die sonne war ich
das eigentlich für quatsch halte wir
bleiben jetzt in die stundenlang sitzen
sondern trinkt nur kurz fassen da gehen
wir auch weiter und so viel ist jetzt
hier auch nicht los was was soll jetzt
passieren an der frischen luft auch
rosol forscher halten die verbote an der
frischen luft für überzogen draußen ist
man sehr sicher
ja es gibt eigentlich nur eine situation
wo man draußen sich wirklich infizieren
kann wenn man sich direkt mit einem
gegenüber unterhält und der gegenüber in
der erosion wolke des anderen drin steht
also relativ dicht aneinander steht
ich würd mal sagen dichter als einen
meter die stadt düsseldorf aber spricht
von erfolg bilder wie diese vom letzten
wochenende habe es nicht mehr gegeben
dieses wochenende sei deutlich
entspannter so ein sprecher der stadt
und teils schriftlich mit es waren
zahlreiche ansprachen und belehrungen
nötig die angesprochenen waren aber in
der regel einsichtig auch hamburg setzt
auf strengere regeln im freien
verschärfte masken pflicht an besonders
beliebten orten wie der außenalster das
sichtlich weniger menschen als am
vergangenen wochenende unterwegs sind
liegt aber wohl vor allem an den
deutlich niedrigeren temperaturen sich
bei arkona unbedingt an die
verhaltensregeln halten das schärft
gesundheitsminister jens spahn fast
täglich den deutschen ein
im oktober hatte er selbst sondern einem
privaten abendessen mit rund einem
dutzend gästen teilgenommen
heute verteidigt sich sparen in der bild
am sonntag die veranstaltung habe allen
coroner regeln entsprochen und er habe
niemanden angesteckt am tag nach dem
essen war sparen selbst positiv getestet
wurden
die bundesregierung stuft das
französische département moselle jetzt
als so genanntes virusvarianten gebiet
ein
damit gelten ab dienstag strenge
auflagen für die einreise nach
deutschland modell grenzt an das
saarland und in rheinland pfalz in mosel
hat sich das südafrikanische virus die
südafrikanische virus mutation stark
ausgebreitet
und deshalb soll der
grenzüberschreitende öffentliche
nahverkehr gestoppt werden berufspendler
müssen einen negativen test vorliegen
in myanmar spitzt sich die lage
dramatisch zu 18 tote werden heute
gemeldet nach protesten
der blutigste tag seit dem beginn der
landesweiten demonstrationen gegen das
militär immer brutaler gegen polizei und
soldaten gegen die demonstranten vor
laut der uno feuern sie auch mit
scharfer munition in die menge
die menschen in myanmar gehen seit einem
monat auf die straßen am ersten februar
hatte sich das militär dort zurück an
die macht geputscht
in hongkong ein weiterer harter schlag
gegen die demokratie bewegung 47
aktivisten werden jetzt angeklagt einige
mussten heute auf einer polizeistation
erscheinen ihnen wird unter anderem
verschwörung zum umsturz vorgeworfen
grundlage ist das sogenannte das
umstrittene sogenannte sicherheitsgesetz
westliche staaten werfen china vor
bürgerrechte in hongkong auszuhöhlen und
die opposition zu unterdrücken und damit
sind wir in dieser sendung beim sonntags
sport
da gibt es große verzweiflung und
riesenbeben bei schlusslicht schalke 04
nach dem gestrigen 1 zu 5 debakel in
stuttgart nur neun punkte in 23
bundesligaspielen die konsequenz dass
aus der sportlichen führung um trainer
christian gross sie tragen ihre große
liebe schon zu grabe die fans auf
schalke heute mittag der sportliche
offenbarungseid veröffentlicht auf der
webseite des vereins
trainer christian gross muss nach 63
tagen gehen auch für sport vorstand
jochen schneider und den leiter der
lizenzspielerabteilung sascha riether
ist das königsblaue kapitel beendet die
getroffenen entscheidungen sind nach den
enttäuschenden auftritten gegen dortmund
und stuttgart unausweichlich geworden
peter knäbel bisher leiter der knappen
schmiede hat bis auf weiteres das
sportliche sagen er muss schnell den
fünften schalker trainer in dieser
saison finden und den klub für die
zweite liga aufstellen denn bei aller
tristesse und erfolgslosigkeit die
hoffnung auf bessere zeiten ist nach wie
vor da tag 4 bei den nordischen
ski-weltmeisterschaften in oberstdorf
und zwei medaillen für die deutschen
zuerst silber für die kombinierer und
dann echt überraschend sogar gold im
mixed skispringen
gemischtes team einzigartige gefühle
deutschland springt im mixed-wettbewerb
überraschend zur goldmedaille
lokalmatadorin katharina hall 1000
liefert mit zwei tollen sprüngen von
ihrer oberstdorfer heimschanze die phase
ist nach markus eisenbichler und anna
rupprecht redet der gestrige wm-zweite
karl geiger für team deutschland 99
eineinhalb meter gold vor norwegen und
österreich
vier männer ein jubelschrei silber für
die deutschen kombinierer frenzel bringt
deutschland beim skisprung mit 107
metern hinter österreich in
lauerstellung wm-debütant weber fällt im
langlauf auf rang vier zurück aber die
routiniers riesler und fenster bringen
schlussläufer geiger auf platz zwei die
spur
souveräner titelverteidiger norwegen mit
einzel-weltmeister rieber vinzenz geiger
sichert silber köster und morgen ist
ruhetag in obersdorf finnland christin
sodann können uns jetzt alle gemeinsam
noch das wetter angucken lohnt sich im
norden halten sich teils dichte nebel
teils dichte wolken und zäher nebel so
rum
aber auch da wird es dann besser in der
mitte und im süden den ganzen tag
sonnenschein höchsttemperaturen zwischen
6 und 14 grad und auch in den nächsten
tagen gibt es für die meisten viel sonne
bei steigenden temperaturen wie schön so
von uns allen hier bei den heute
-nachrichten vielen dank dass sie dabei
waren nächste woche ist petra gerster an
dieser stelle für sie da und nachher um
21 uhr 45 übernimmt die kollegin
marietta slomka mit dem heute journal
machen sie sich einen sehr angenehmen
sonntagabend zum beispiel mit berlin
direkt